est ce que vous vous souvenez de
l'endroit où vous avez garer votre
voiture en arrivant ce soir
je vous dis ça parce que je connais
quelqu'un qui en moins de dix secondes
est capable de déverrouiller n'importe
quel système de voiture et partir avec
il s'appelle tally il en a fait un
trafic et je vais rencontrer en prison
quand j'étais aumônier de prison à la
maison d'arrêt des hommes de nanterre
j'ai rencontré des centaines de
prisonniers
mais le plus marqué ce qu'ils étaient
enfermés à deux ou trois par cellule de
9 mètres carrés
22 heures sur 24 a rien faire toute la
journée
la prison avant d'y être allé on peut
pas imaginer ce que c'est c'est du béton
des barbelés des miradors
et beaucoup de bruit c'est des cris
des bruits de clés de serrures
des gens qui tapent dans les portes
nuitées jour
un truc à devenir complètement fou et
d'ailleurs certains le deviennent ou
alors complètement déstructurée or
toutes ces personnes vont un jour sortir
de prison
il ya des gens ils vont
chercher à changer le monde avec des
grands mouvements des grandes idées à
mon niveau je me suis juste dit qu'est
ce que je peux faire pour ces gars et
j'ai rencontré olivier olivier avec qui
j'ai monté une chorale en prison et lui
il avait besoin d'une promesse
d'embauché
ils étaient très motivés pour faire
autre chose de sa vie alors je suis allé
voir un de mes amis qui était chef
d'entreprise et je lui ai dit est ce que
tu acceptes de lui donner une chance
il a dit oui et olivier et pendant sept
ans dans cette même entreprise et puis
ça s'est su dans la prison
les autres détenus venaient me voir dans
cette vidéo il paraît que tu as trouvé
du boulot pour olivier et moi
alors comme c'étaient des personnes qui
avaient envie de changer de vie je vais
aller voir d'autres chefs d'entreprise
pour les convaincre c'est tout simple
c'était en
2.1 en france on a un gros sujets liés à
la récidive
la plupart des détenus retourne en
prison un tiers d'entre eux retournent
en prison dans l'année qui suit leur
sortie de prison et ça va jusqu'à deux
tiers dans les cinq ans
une espèce de boucle infernale
il sert pas à grand chose
et le deuxième point c'est qu'en fait
une personne incarcérée
ça coûte à la société ça nous coûte à
tous
cinquante mille euros par an
il ya donc
affaire donc on a trouvé 1 puis 4 puis
20 emplois
sauf que assez vite les chefs
d'entreprise m'ont appelé m'ont dit
bien sympa tega sauf que ils n'arrivent
jamais à l'heure
quand ils viennent pas ils préviennent
pas ils ont des comportements
compliqué ça va devenir difficile
donc là on s'est dit on a loupé quelque
chose en tout cas moi je me suis dit
j'ai peut-être été un peu naïve de
croire que le boulot une fois qu'on
l'avait c'était bon
en fait on a raté
le retour à une vie qu'il ne connaissait
pas
en fait ils avaient besoin de découvrir
qui ils étaient eux-mêmes d'apprendre à
se connaître
vous avez besoin d' apprendre à être
fiers
d'appartenir à une société
tiers
d'appartenir à la france
pierre de même fier de travailler
et il avait besoin d'avoir de répondre à
de multiples autres en jeu juste le
boulot
la prison ça fonctionne on est d'accord
mais aussi 7 des structures
et bien on allait restructurer
et donc
on a réfléchi j'ai besoin de trouver un
logement de travailler sur l'endettement
les addictions leurs liens familiaux
les difficultés qu'ils avaient en
sortant de prison
et du coup on a commencé par créer un
café philo entre un prof de philosophie
qui venait et qui travaillait avec eux
sur une thématique qui choisissait
chaque fois pour l'atelier d'après poste
et la paix et l amour de la confiance
ils ont découvert qu'ils pouvaient
penser par eux-mêmes qu'ils pouvaient
avoir des avis différents
il pouvait avoir des idées et respecter
les idées des autres ensuite on s'est
dit ils ont besoin d'apprendre à
s'exprimer à mieux s'exprimer mais pour
se présenter pour
être aussi mettre des mots sur
la violence ou la colère qu'ils avaient
onu
la semaine dernière j'étais à marseille
sur le site de marseille et il y en a un
qui m'a dit c'est avant moi je parlais
wesh wesh wesh c'est lui qui disait ça
et
jamais j'avais imaginé qu'un jour je
pourrai parler à votre monde
en fait ils venaient de découvrir qu'il
allait devoir quitter ses codes de sa
cité et
découvrir les codes de la société
en fait on a découvert aussi qu'ils
avaient besoin de recréer des liens de
s'appuyer aussi sur des liens de
confiance des liens sincères des liens
chaleureux de d'apprendre à être en
vérité face à eux mêmes et face aux
autres alors on a créé des groupes de
paroles des déjeuners et des dîners
une autre chose aussi on pour créer ce
lien un des moyens c'était
d'apprendre le service
faire du service du coup on a créé un
restaurant
le quai liberté qui est pas loin d'ici
allez-y c'est sur les quais de seine en
juste en bas de beaugrenelle
et dans notre restaurant ils font du
service
ils ont découvert aussi la joie de
devoir un client satisfait parce qu'on
est là on avait répondu à sa demande ils
ont aussi appris un métier ils ont
appris à servir ils ont appris à
voir qu'on était aussi heureux parce
qu'on leur avait fait confiance
et puis
on a aussi découvert que de parfaits de
par ses liens
en fait
ils avaient besoin
conte l'heure de retrouver aussi voilà
d'autres liens d'avoir besoin de nous
sortir de prison c'est pas simple
en fait je crois qu'on a trouvé une
solution
paraît fonctionner
au bout de deux ou trois mois
en fait on voyait les épaules voûtées
qui se redressait
vous voyez des visages froid
but refermer s'adoucissent et
on voyait
des sourires
la fierté qu'ils apparaissaient sur les
visages
du coup on s'est dit qu'on était dans la
bonne direction
en fait ce dont on s'est aperçu c'est
que ces personnes étaient capables de
transformer leur existence
faire un vrai changement de vie et
d'agir positivement dans la société
alors est-ce que c'est du restart du
reset
est pas un redémarrage pour refaire et
retomber dans les mêmes galères il avait
connu c'est un nouveau départ pour faire
quelque chose de beau quelque chose de
grand de leur vie
c'est changer de regard sur soi
le regard sur les autres et c'est ce
qu'a fait thalys aujourd'hui les chefs
d'entreprise et il a inventé un système
pour éviter que vos voitures soient
volés il le vend aux grands groupes
automobiles
[Applaudissements]
est ce que ce serait parce a changé le
monde
et si ça dépendait
de nous
vous